hi everybody um I hope y'all here for
building your first data pipelines I'm
going to be talking about why you should
build a pipeline and how you should
document it and mostly demonstrate the
use of the school Luigi which is what
we're going to workshop together it's
group it's a workshop so it's going to
be hands-on you're gonna form groups
later on during this session with your
tablemates speak we can try it it's
apparently I will try to see if it will
work and if not I will just speak really
loudly and project a little more can
folks hear me alright channel one yeah
there we go all right we have a
microphone so if you are gonna be
participating in the cutting section of
this workshop I'd ask that you try and
start just saw Luigi and folium right
now we're also gonna rely on pandas and
so I can't learn which should be
installed if you're running anaconda if
you're not
I either recommend you use it which we
sent out before the tutorial or you can
install it using the other methods
appropriate to your particular machine
but hopefully we can get to a point
where there's at least a couple laptops
on each table working but I will get
started with the sort of talk and
section of this presentation so I'm
hunter Owens I'm a data scientist for
the city of Los Angeles this is building
your first data pipelines so we're gonna
talk today about why you might need a
data pipeline for me these are the
reasons I use one one is to organize my
own method of work the second is because
I often need to edit and rerun these
things and the third reason is so I can
appropriate I can collaborate with other
people so just show of hands in the room
how many people in this room have sort
of built sort of scripts that pull data
from somewhere do something to it and
then report it out to some others just
uh yeah so
that's the thing we do all the time it's
basically I suspect if it's your job is
like mine it is a lot of your job and
it's often a hassle because how many of
those skirts broke yeah they broke they
always do so that's why we need robust
data pipelines we need our plumbing to
work and not crash and die at 2:00 in
the morning not speaking from experience
at all in that case so there's a lot of
tools out there that help you document
how your data goes from some external
system a website an API what have you
into your own system so there's make
which is actually a build system there's
this great blog post by Shermy us kind
of it's called using make as your data
pipeline tool I'd highly recommend you
read it it's a great blog post I will
link to it in the repo at some point
tonight a lot of people use shell
scripts how many of you use shell
scripts to do this process all right
cool so watch shell scripts how many
views like a pure Python script alright
so that's how many views Drake a couple
um and then anybody know how to use an
AWS data pipeline yeah is there so
there's some sort of wild listed those
in those order was because make shell
scripts Python scripts for this audience
a lot of you have seen these before it's
pretty simple it's just like a
declarative set of steps essentially
like step one step two step three done
Drake and AWS are really powerful tools
that you can use especially the AWS data
pipeline toolkit it's got a lot of
documentation JSON configuration and
it's it's a lot but I'm here today to
talk about Luigi which was developed at
Spotify and is builds entirely in Python
and this it's not kidding can you all
okay cool so that's what we're gonna
demonstrate using today but I did want
to like sort of start this talk by
saying there are lots of different tools
to do this and when you're building your
native product you should or data you
know
you're doing your analysis you just
think about like hey maybe this there
are definitely times I still just use
Python scripture shell scripts because
like I don't need to use a Luigi it's
overkill or and there's definitely times
like I've seen the AWS to a bit use to
more effectively to this but Luigi is
nice for a lot of reasons one is it's
entirely written in Python
I like Python it is what I use
day-to-day so not having to like learn
how to configure AWS and like all this
obscure based on all the time or try to
remember how make syntax works I never
remember anything syntax worse the other
thing is it produces a graph of your
data dependencies so what's really nice
is it requires you by writing Luigi
tasks and targets you've essentially
defined the relationship between all the
different pieces of analysis and store
pieces of data on your system and
therefore it also it is really easy to
plot right on because I can just say
clone the repo and run this and it won't
generally work once you have configured
on somebody else's machine because it's
just Python and then finally it really
has a nice level of scale which is like
it's both appropriate when you're
working on the local file system and
then also appropriate when you're
working with like a spark or the new
cluster and you don't have to
necessarily rewrite a ton of stuff if
you switch between those two
environments so it's it's middle weight
in terms of the tools it's not as
lightweight as a make or shell script
it's also not as heavyweight as some of
the sort of big data cloud solutions but
I don't have big data a lot I work for a
city government we so some first
principles about how Luigi works it's
kind of this idea of everything should
be an atomic operation on some sort of
final type system so this is my Python
little script that I did to do some sort
of data analysis I've got a little code
base module and it's got some functions
generating features
and deploy the predictions how many of
you have written something like this in
the past all right cool
so this happens I put it in Carranza put
a put up a cron job I need to do this
every night for example one of the
things I did at my job is every month we
had a job that helped predict weather
led what were the odds of lead poisoning
at certain different houses within the
city of Chicago where I used to live and
we wanted to send off a list of
recommendations of which homes should be
inspected each month to the city's
Department of Public Health so that was
a no task and this happens well not
literally a doesn't define error but
what happens is something brace and when
you've got expensive operations like
fitting a model or loading it a bunch of
data into Postgres there are some that
takes you know often an hour to to run
it's really annoying when you screw it
up on the syntax on the third step and
then you've got to rerun an hour worth
of code it's so you end up doing
something like this yeah see I had this
example um you want to start resuming
things only at the breaking step which
is like I we know who steps 1 2 & 3 ran
successfully
let's or we know step 1a 1b and 1c ran
successfully or 1t did not and this is
like downloading data from a portal or
using an API so the idea of reducing
everything to like a single unit
operations on either a file or a
database is really useful in terms of
like restarting these jobs and also just
documenting how this goes about so we
end up writing something like this so we
saw that generate eaters it
one conditions we have in the past and
you can write something that sounds like
if the feature is TSV doesn't exist
Jeremy the features if the model and his
not that pendulum model and if the
predictions day is not today with one of
the predictions so that's great but this
is ugly
now imagine if we had ten different data
sources you needed to combine you needed
to fit the model the edit test and train
two different models and compare the
results and then you need to deploy them
with some sort of weird non regular
schedule like it's not today like this
isn't too ugly but this gets really ugly
and hard to document very fast so Luigi
introduces two pieces of abstraction for
you to build that without making it look
super ugly which are two types of Python
pockets so what is a task a task is a
unit of work so it's a piece of analysis
and so downloading downloading something
from an API it's whatever sort of whom
you want to run then it's target is a
representation of the state of state of
information so this can be a Keiko file
certain rows in a database updated a
table in the database local files a ship
a new file system files their relation
DFS right yeah so let's take a look at
what they look like so here is a very
very simple task so you take you saw
possibly do not ask I've given in this
parameter which is to say like you might
have passed it was a different friend
there's in this case the default frame
that is going to but we can change it
and then there is this enormous surplus
always all passed in once I plus three
different methods the first method is
and this is some other set of attacks it
is your first task in the pipeline use
the external class that I'll show you
that in a bit but you can see that for
my pastor well some other possible have
had to be run and whatever target some
of their class produces needs to already
exists so can you see we've got run here
which is opens up the file of rights
coming around and then close the file
and then finally in our run method and
that's the code that we're gonna execute
and then like how there we go huh
come on stay there we go
seriously steak so I'm gonna pull this
up in that terminal and run in and
hopefully nothing is going to break yeah
so that so that particular example won't
work because there is no some other
there's no proceeding step so I'm going
to show you an example without a
proceeding step yeah so let me make this
can you all read this awesome
so where did I save this so if we look
at example de PUE I I'll lay on this is
easy on some external tasks that's
basically just a quick thing to say this
is a task that does not require any
other task it exists sort of first and
then we've got a run method so just
outputting some long run
right into the temp directory and it
actually handles if the fou folder
doesn't exist it's going to handle
creating that for us which is really
nice
yes if temp doesn't exist so let's so if
we it's gonna be hard - it's gonna be
hard to like type and hold the mic so
I'm just gonna try and talk really
loudly if you folks in the back can't
hear me I will figure out a way to make
it work
yeah they got this is the mic for the
recording so give me once let's uh yeah
thanks sorry sorry y'all I neglected to
volunteer for this job Jackie's gonna
kill me yeah back in data pipelines and
then we can go type on - M
Luigi - tasks module example so that's
the name of the file and then it's my
task and no I forgot to throw it and you
also need to throw this local scheduler
flag so there's actually a Luigi game
and I'll explain this in a short bit
that lets you sort of schedule jobs on
like a cluster or on your own machine so
the local scheduler is just built in
it's how you quickly hack and run code
very fast so run that and you'll see
checking if my task is come so here I
can press yes can you turn your
brightness up cuz I can't read it over
your shoulder yeah there we go so there
you don't work at this time every delay
distributing this unit of work which
although this just even thing to do if
we're running it on a laptop if you
haven't have a cluster of machines you
can see you
but for you so there's one scheduled
task and it has one dependency which is
itself which is my Testament for Emma 42
and it didn't run because if we go look
in my temp directory here I'll just want
hand it that's easy
if we look at my temp directory you'll
see that there's already the fou folder
and a bunch of different examples from
when I ran this when I was debugging
this code this morning but if we were to
change it and we give it per am and then
once somebody's favorite number that
isn't 42 aim so it's gonna run the task
is successful and what's interesting
here is just reminding is this actually
ran this time but notice that the last
time that he did actually run because
the target which was food water - 42 dot
CSV already existed so it was like this
- I don't even rerun this computational
job that we barely wrote any lines of
code and we already got that like fairly
tricky piece of ETL logic built into our
system so that's super useful so if what
happens if for example we were to remove
the entire temp food folder well try to
actually spell it correctly first and we
ran it again with a works again it will
create the folder you can see this in
bar eight exists but Barney and then we
run it again it's gonna run progress
looks good but there's didn't run any
tests so that's sort of the like here's
my neat trick
you're not going to be rerunning scripts
that of our
ran before because you've managed to
turn everything into an atomic file
operation so that's our first little
example task so you might ask me but
hunter Mike ETL process is in database
not in file systems late this is not
just about being abundant out of the box
you get supported for s3 targets and
moisturised tables a CMS files a query
and it's very easy as subclass target to
produce your own custom target class
slug if you learn like file system you
operate on or database so you in this
subclass primates started doing its own
update logic to see if something exists
or does not exist you know the question
is asking does this exist so how do you
run this interface for visualizing your
process and sort of what's happened so
I'm gonna start the Beeman and show you
what that interface looks like but for
the purposes of this workshop we are
only going to rely the local scheduler
yeah yeah so we can start Luigi the
daemon by typing Luigi D it started up
I'll go back to the folder
and let's just nuke the entire food nuke
the entire food directory for now and so
I'm gonna get rid of this local
scheduler option but first I'm gonna go
to the localhost 8:08
right now it's got no pending tasks no
running past no done tasks but for those
of you who work at larger companies with
data teams that are larger than mine you
might have a whole group working on ETL
steps and this is very helpful to have a
centralized server that can tell you how
everybody's upstream tasks are doing and
such so nothing right now send it off a
job refresh and look it ran my task with
parameter 8 here's the time there's a
priority queue for when you have like
lots of different tasks to run and a
whole graph but for now there you go you
can send it off again it's not gonna run
and see it's only done one task still
because it said this already ran we
already had with parameter 8 can send it
with the default parameters will get
another task again different timestamp
so that is the magic additionally for
those of you who are like like me I
mostly just use like a script that had
so I always like writing like Python
final name WI is how I run scripts so
you add this rules and it's inside or
you're running inside of Jupiter
notebook and you're wondering how do I
really need to have even had Luigi got
run and the task name and any sort of
flags for my data is a list and it will
let you run the movie via the script
that you wrote it in so it's often
useful to have that like little magic
incantation at the end because so I just
really fighting for remember like Luigi
- my mom's room I'm gonna you know this
you can throw your code and make it
really
you can get back to the old type on
finally in my it runs it works it's
super useful you can also just use that
inside a jupiter notebook on that you've
defined a task in and it will run inside
the notebook so that's also useful for
those of you who used you their
notebooks for your development
environment because people are like well
how do i do that so the other question I
get a lot about this is sometimes the
interpreted state is not actually a text
file or database table the interpreted
state is you take it afraid you ran
value Council on it and now you want to
so the nice thing is you sprite pickle
miles to transfer them there so this is
an example that creates an empty data
frame raise it to a paper file and then
so that's how you can pass data frames
or scikit-learn bottles that's useful
one might buyer beware pickles it is
like only learn pickles from trusted
sources so don't just have have this
generally being like one pipeline don't
be like pulling in pickle files from
like s3 you might not know we're like
having this be created on one machine
for security purposes you can read more
about this in the documentation for
pickle so this is the routing portion of
workshop if you guys important like one
to two groups for a table or so I know
there's a bunch of you in the back sort
of right and take one person is sort of
type and you guys I've got a situation
you want I'm out data analysts for the
city of Washington DC and the city of
Washington DC has been so kind to put up
permits data on their website
so yeah there's open data and if you
search term it's well you'll see that
the city has actually shared the
building permits they've issued from
2012 through 2016 on their website and
what I've given you is if you go to
bitly /pi data - DC - pipelines you'll
actually get this presentation in a very
meta sense of presentation that links
upon itself but you'll also get this
example DC pipeline which is a Luigi
pipeline that has none of the conrod so
I have some questions of this data that
I have a pretty valid answer like which
word has seen the most development in
last four years how can we combine these
four different data sets into a single
data set so there's a year's dictionary
that will give you links to those CSV so
you don't have to go or individually
copy/paste those but I would recommend
claiming that repo and it's set so you
can run the first task is going to be
the download task and you'll see how
each task depends on the test prior to
it by looking for the definition
requires and you can see that it's set
to a deployment in it beautiful but
here's some interesting questions I'm
going to see how y'all on into them I
would be coming around answering
questions you can formally group for a
table or a half table depending on the
table crowded it is I've found this
exercise works better looking like two
or three people you know to six people
like working on one machine rather than
just one person by yourself so let's get
hacking let's figure out how many to the
city
yeah and let me know if not get Wi-Fi on
at least one machine I know this issue
the earlier shows about that all right
sweet so we've got 15 more minutes and I
know not everybody made it through
because this is not designed to be
finished within the time frame I gave
you so please do not worry about that
what I will do is up on that given up by
the end of the day once I finish
squashing a few more bugs will be like a
nicely documented version of this you
can refer to the other thing I didn't
want to demonstrate was that you don't
have to just use files because we were
just playing around with files today so
I'm gonna do that for about 5 minutes
and then I can do QA for the last 10 or
you can continue acting on stuff so the
other thing is inside the Ouija there's
a lot of barely let's be honest barely
documented this is like one of the flaws
and the package is like they don't tell
you that they actually have like an
entire insert to a stress thing that's
really easy so this program actually if
you're in this you instead of inheriting
from tasks you inherit from copy to
table and then you just give it the
Communists overwrite the column
attributes and if there's a CSV with
those pairs that it's reading from our
text file that's going to insert that
into Postgres just copy to table that's
really quick with only a few lines of
code so that's really useful it's also
really useful I am don't know why my
markdown do not render here but this is
all you need to do to get a query out of
Postgres or bigquery is the similar
syntax so you know the Collins
dictionary which you can actually
generate programmatically and then
Postal Service and it can require any
sort of other dependencies that create
that table so that's really useful also
you can step this up from simply batch
processing on a local machine to batch
processing on something like spark if
you had if I don't mean worked out
copyright this is which is really easy
you just give it configuration you know
early and then just give it a name and a
example County why in the repo and then
Luigi also has lots of different
configuration options which is useful
because you might want to say the
development and the production server
you can find this together with an
operating on like different ingredients
from leading to fairly small fairly
quickly so you have like stuff that
needs to be done using safari to do but
by step three you're already at the
stage where you can throw it in memory
in Python it's a lot easier to write
your analysis in Python this is one
pipeline they can handle all of that and
you can use the configuration to sort of
keep track of your secrets like your
database connections and such so that's
um here's a couple examples the opening
here is this massive Python package that
I developed at my old job the dopant
source that sort of led me down this
whole road of like insanity ETL because
there were 20 different energy utilities
that are all submitting utility data
that means to be duped on an hourly
basis and this is how I know someone's
to modify presentation and I suppose
over there
there questions about that otherwise QA
come on some mystery want to continue
hiking on their projects yeah it's there
so once you know like my parameter late
it needs to be run on a order that's
probably yeah and now the question was
from the new communities like is there
any way to force a task to be rerun in
to make sure that the target is Austria
that doesn't this basically yeah I would
say generally certainly Dayton would the
neighbors if the natives like tomorrow
theoretically tomorrow is run shouldn't
exist so we kick off the rundown will
say oh we ran this one over the last 300
days but not today
today's press yes thank you
last question back there yeah so in
terms of like I'll shoot amenities I'm
speaking for my requires is actually
competed returns different things so
tasks a and Cassie me you can say
requires time which returning plastic on
the task being also have examples like
work in the fridge dataset function when
it requires clean CSP but for every
different parameter of the last twenty
years so there's two types of runs that
I think about we did not dream was
whether okay it requires step one or it
requires a step one a step one be 7 1 C
depends right all right anything is so
much for an apprentice training and you
know this is like sort of hands-on and
weird so workshop so one off or
playing along and learn something you
can find the other and asking questions